the speech last night
was
paradoxically
the least interesting and most
interesting speech Trump has ever given
most interesting because it went was
intentionally the least interesting we
knew from the top we knew from the very
top of the speech
Trump was going to announce how did we
know because they announced it before he
got on stage
president and first lady of the United
States of America president Donald J
Trump accompanied by Mrs Melania Trump
so there you have it right there from
the open it's not the former president
it's not the Donald it's this is the
future president and the future first
lady okay
so he comes on he milks the Lee
Greenwood song You Know proud to be and
American Trump's just there totally was
he seemed energetic he seemed ready to
go nice and bronzed vigorous full of
life the guy does not really seem to age
it's amazing to think he came down that
golden escalator
2015. at seven years ago it's a long
time especially when you're up there in
your 70s Trump
seemed basically as young and vigorous
as he ever did maybe it's the aspartame
and the diet coke has just sort of
pickled him and he he doesn't age but
either way this was not a Joe Biden
scenario he came up he looked he looked
pretty strong he looked pretty vigorous
but this was not a 2015 speech this was
not the Mexican rapists are killing
everybody and we need to deport them and
we got to get tough on crime
this was an elegant speech as he put it
in fact he didn't even really focus on
the 2020 election was stolen kind of
line that Trump has been harping on for
the past two years he touched on it but
only a little bit briefly and only with
a little bit of a wink
for the first time in memory China was
reeling and
back on its heels you've never seen that
before
because the United States was out doing
them on every single front and China was
paying billions and billions of dollars
in taxes and tariffs the farmers know
that because they got 28 billion of it
no president had ever sought or received
one dollar
for our country from China until I came
along and we were getting hundreds of
billions of dollars
many people think that because of this
China played a very active role in the
2020 election just saying just saying
sure that didn't happen
so this this was an important piece of
rhetoric here because
it shows you one Trump
was not going to focus on 2020 was
stolen
we see that he didn't touch at all on
the questions about voting machines and
the recounts and the dragging on the
count until a week later he didn't focus
on that at all he did focus on
some interference from China
but he did so in a lighthearted way this
wasn't a Madman Driven Crazy by by
having the election stolen from him and
pulling his hair out it was with a
little bit of a wink and a nod listen I
would I'm just saying okay we would
never talk about that but look China
maybe they did it I mean moves on
it it I suspect was in that speech to
Signal he's not going to give up on the
issue of election Integrity but he's not
going to let it dominate his thinking
this is a man
as he presents himself who is in control
of his emotions and can even sort of
make a joke about something really awful
that he believes happened
then he focused the whole thing on the
future
for a while he used this phrase and I
couldn't quite figure out what the
phrase meant but it's a really brilliant
little piece of political rhetoric see
if you can figure out what the phrase
means
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
together we will be taking on the most
corrupt forces and entrenched interests
imaginable our country is in a
horrible State we're in grave trouble
this is not a task for a politician or a
conventional candidate this is a task
for a great movement that embodies the
courage confidence and the spirit of the
American people this is a movement this
is not for
any one individual this will not be my
campaign this will be our campaign all
together
so I got I got those moments wrong in
the in the speech that the piece of
rhetoric there that's really really
important is Trump answering his critics
who say you're a narcissist and
everything's about you and Trump is
saying it's not about me this is about
you and it's about us together it
Harkens back to that really brilliant
moment of rhetoric in the 2016 campaign
when Hillary had unveiled her motto I'm
with her
and he said I'm with her uh-uh that's
not my motto I'm with you that's my
motto
totally changes the subject even of that
motto for Hillary the subject was all
these little peasants are just you know
paying obeisance
and pledging fealty to her her majesty
Hillary and with Trump he says no no
it's my campaign and I'm saying look I
am with you and the campaign even though
I'm the one running it it's really all
about you and Trump finally got back to
that and I think it answers the
narcissism charge
then there was a really curious piece of
rhetoric in there that that did leave me
scratching my head a little bit figure
out if you can if you can
get what it means
one of the beautiful things of the pause
if there is such a thing as a beautiful
thing but one of the the important
factors of the pause is that we see how
bad they've done
so we will be able to do it properly and
it will be much easier everybody will
agree with us because everybody sees
what a bad job has been done during this
two-year period and it will be a
four-year period everybody sees that it
will be much easier for us to do what
has to be done the pause the pause what
is the pause oh the pause is the Biden
Administration which is not the movement
that came in to defeat Trump and Maga
it's just this little pause between the
inevitable
first and second Administration for
Donald Trump it's a smart piece of
rhetoric and it's the sort of thing
we've seen from him before Trump always
pushes you past the set the sale but
this is a point that Scott Adams uh made
very clear in 2016. the Trump he goes so
so far he says listen we're going to
round up every single illegal in this
country and Deport every single one of
them because they're all rapists and
murderers and you say what what are you
talking about he says no okay we'll just
Deport some of them and you've already
accepted the premise that we're going to
deport anybody at all and so he he kind
of brings you along he just plants these
seeds in your mind so by saying this was
the pause already in your mind you've
got this idea oh of course there's going
to be a second Trump Administration yeah
I don't really like this Biden
Administration pause but I'm looking
forward to the inevitable second Trump
term
Trump then came back to
to a theme that he did it in a subtle
way but he also came back to a theme
that made clear that he is not going to
just be running some squishy cut your
taxes GOP establishment kind of campaign
he talked about the center of American
Life
we will defend the rights of parents and
we will defend the family as the center
of American Life
but who would think standing up here 10
years ago 15 years ago that a politician
and I don't like to think of myself as a
politician but I guess that's what I am
I hate that thought but that a
politician would be up saying we will
defend parental rights of course you can
offend to who would think that we even
have to mention this who would think it
even should be a subject to be talked
about we have to defend parental rights
can you believe this
now you love that bit you love to hear
that from Trump
even beyond the point on family which
we'll get to in a second when he says
listen I come up here I'm a politician
do I have to say that I hate the idea
that I'm a politician but I guess I am
the disingenuous
oily slick career politician he would
say
oh I'm not a politician maybe I'm a
public servant but I'm not a politician
no no it's about something greater than
me
Trump comes up
and he actually is not a career
politician he's only been a politician
for about six seven years
but he says am I I guess I am a
politician okay I hate that idea because
I don't like politicians but I guess I
am one
it's that it's that Honesty that I think
people found refreshing even if some
people felt the speech should have been
more fiery I kind of was hoping that it
would be more fiery there is a common
theme that I saw
cropping up on social media even from
some of Trump's critics which is people
saying you know I just I like the guy
one of the great listeners to this show
Brita who we've you know there's some
people who are you know they're really
in the the Inner Circle
of the of the DW crew and I saw her pop
up on Twitter she says uh I just like
the guy you just can't convince me not
to like the guy I kind of I was talking
to friends of mine they said you know
yeah just made me kind of miss him made
me think oh you know I remember that
that was nice I missed that guy when he
says that the family is the center of
American life this is an important
statement about political philosophy
because there are two views on the
subject
there is the view that the family is the
center of American Life
and there's the view that the individual
is the center of American political life
and the libs believe that it's the
individual they want to destroy the
family and they want to first break
Society down into atomized individuals
then they want to gather them up into
this sort of homogeneous ugly Collective
the Libertarians also tend to view the
individual as the center of American
Life
because they they think that our
politics essentially come down to
natural rights and entitlements that we
get as individuals
conservatives don't think that the
traditional conservative perspective is
no individuals have their place but the
fundamental building block of society is
not the atomized individual it is the
family that's the fundamental political
unit Trump is siding with that
traditional point of view that's not the
that's not exactly the libertarian point
of view that's not the neoconservative
point of view that's not the liberal
point of view that's not the leftist
point of view that is the traditional
conservative point of view and that is
the lane that Trump had success in in
2016 and I I if he's going to have
success in 2024 that will have to be his
Lane as well you know the rest of the
show is going to continue now when we
talk about a story that really has
fascinated me the FTX collapse this is
the second largest crypto Exchange in
the world it was run by the second
largest donor to the Democrat Party
during the midterm elections and it's
this guy who prattles on and on and on
about what a wonderful guy he is Sam
freed and uh he he's he's this uh sort
of holier than now lib this premium
virtue signaler and it turns out he's
one of the biggest scam artists of the
century the whole thing collapsed I
don't know anything about crypto so I'm
interviewing Eric Voorhees who is who is
one of the OG is truly one of the
experts and leaders in the whole Space
we've got that coming up on the member
block if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]